hot breath how did you generate a local
following
you um they local you they in town
yeah you it's like you constantly invite
people man
when i started and i think that was the
biggest thing that i hated about young
comics
in social media when i started i
literally wouldn't invite anybody to
come see me
okay any and every person hey brother i
do stand up i'll be at this spot
if you couldn't make it this time maybe
it's one time you me i'm still going to
tell you
verbatim out my mouth that i do stand up
that's who i am
and people just kept coming to see me
and the reason why they kept coming to
see me they've been seeing me in houston
for 18 years they can never say that i'm
the same
they've watched me grow from year one
to year 19. nor do i say the same jokes
nor am i repeating the same things i i
have a hard time doing the same set
if i'm doing two shows in the same night
i'm not gonna do the same exact set
is all your writing on stage or you
pinned to paper pen to paper pen the
paper off stage paper i love to hear
that